[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube somebody
done [ __ ] up again now for those of
you who don't know recently there was a
band who made a sorry-ass music video
called Asian girl now I said how much
would it be that I wasn't gonna go ahead
and talk about this [ __ ]
but the more I sat on it the more pissed
off I started to get this video is about
a band that is started to go ahead and
make the song ridiculing the Asian
culture mmm
Mitch buckle go all elbows I want you
dull know each other this let's get
started
but let's not even talk about the white
boys in the band let's talk about that
asian girl hey [ __ ] dil that's right
[ __ ] I said [ __ ] you for sending my
people back a few years that's my
husband but maybe I can't beat you man
that check Skylar and Riley because well
there's a bunch of mr. born white boys
cuz see high expect races [ __ ] from
stupid [ __ ] every now and then
baby as an angry Korean man was said or
that's a thoroughly agender not only
this video racist as hell
it's also sexist as fun look at you
[ __ ] not only did you [ __ ] up for a
race in an ethnicity you also [ __ ] it up
for agenda good job
that's right you'll be brown your
stupidest [ __ ] the only way you would
have done this video is if you
internally races just [ __ ] that's why I
said it be out you know elongation boys
huh what you got a Ku Klux Kochi
personally I want to know what the hell
you were thinking when you were opposed
to do this video and I know what you're
gonna say cuz I've heard it a million
times before don't hate me cause I'm
beautiful
judge me complete you'll make money I'm
proud of it nobody's talking about your
money
we are slowly talking about the content
of your character and it sucks dick no
pun intended
what y'all stupid ass cat you you would
like [ __ ] the coloring book look I don't
give a flying [ __ ] up on you on how many
times I froze the video to check out a
72 times what a jump into the dumbest
and I hope your parents are proud of
y'all
I like how you knew it was a racist
video and just in case you had to right
well obviously we're not racist because
one of my bad memories are Indonesian
yeah what the [ __ ] it's not many
Indonesian acts within reach the only
thing you prove right there is that what
are your bad members is stupid as [ __ ]
good job I don't even understand how you
can say you're not racist when you're a
drummer and your electric guitars look
like two Klan members behind you
why fight if we try to be a band you
might split like one direction after a
competition that's right
ching chong Ling Hwa you made a stupid
that song deal with me you ever notice
that everybody who's places always says
some racist [ __ ] but ends it with but
I'm not racist good job on the cover
what the [ __ ] did you think we're gonna
be like [ __ ] swine I drinks I got what
the hell oh but I'm not racist oh sorry
that's my bed that's right [ __ ] I got
high cholesterol the six chin but I'm
not mad I don't feed my kids I'm not a
bad parent
I think nasty things about let me tread
but I'm not racist what that's not the
same you know what House races people
say I'm not racist I have one Asian
friend you can never just have one ain't
your friends we come in back dumbass
would you count your ancient legs what
you have like a limit on the amount of
color people you know another one gingka
one Negro and one [ __ ] that's your
full um yeah this is my bus [ __ ] kill
yourself to be honest with you has
infuriating as it is to see these bugs
trying to make a mockery of my culture
what really pissed me off was to see the
Asian people in the video and I'm saying
again what the [ __ ] would you think it
please and it was hard enough to break
racial stereotypes you want to go ahead
and participate and set us back a few
gears basically you let me train you are
a media presence and you should have
[ __ ] known better
Indonesian do it in bed I don't [ __ ]
know you but it seems that you forgot
that you are ancient so let me go ahead
and refresh your memory base offers
making fun of you your family and your
cultural background and every little bit
of progress that we made in this country
to stop stupid [ __ ] like this from
happening in a way if I give you the
benefit of the doubt and say hey maybe
these guys are trying to be funny either
you're the dumbest [ __ ] people on
earth or you're just [ __ ] races in a
way you lose
you wanted to jump you should ask me I'm
a comedian not that boo there go [ __ ]
yourself
[Music]
you know the duck is so who your
girlfriend
please introduce ease when we shall come
back up sitting out make the [ __ ]